Ah bonjour !
Qu'est ce qui vous amène ?
Ça !
Oui ?
Un couteau ?
Et ?
On est en 2018 !
Je ne demande pas une mitraillette, je ne demande pas un bazooka.
Mais je pourrais pas avoir un pistolet, plutôt qu'un couteau de merde ?
Ça me prend une nuit pour tuer 5 ados, j'ai autre chose à foutre !
Oh bah je vous connais vous !
C'est vous qui sortez des télé tout ça.
Bah non justement, je ne sors plus des télé vu que tout le monde a un Iphone aujourd'hui !
Ah oui, en effet ...
Alors, à la limite hein, une tablette pourquoi pas ! Je passe un pied, je passe l'autre mais je passe pas l'épaule ! Et donc je fais comment moi pour travailler là ?
Vous avez pensé au Airplay ?
Quoi ?
AppleTV, Chromcast...
Sur les millennials ça cartonne !
Bon écoutez, je ne comprends pas ce que vous dites là.
Une fois j'ai fais ça pendant 10 minutes mon frère !
Il était pas mort le mec !
Mais c'est très bien un couteau ! Au moins voilà, c'est original.
T'as déjà fais ça pendant 10 minutes ?
Qu'est ce que vous faites là ?
Vous n'avez pas de plainte ?
Enfaite c'est parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on est sur le point de faire l'amour, on se fait tuer.
C'est un peu contraignant pour nous quoi ...
Oui bon bah ça, je peux comprendre à la limite que c'est chiant mais heu ...
Bon bah moi, je ne suis pas méchant du tout.
Je suis fabriquant de poupée, et je ne sais pas pourquoi les affaires ne marchent pas très bien en ce moment.
C'est étonnant ça !
Oui hein ...
Pourtant tout le monde aime les poupées ?
Bah oui ...
Elles ressemblent à quoi ?
Alors j'ai un premier modèle que je peux vous montrer.
Ah putain !
Elle fait peur ?
Et bah vous le tuer, voilà !
Je vous écoute.
Vous voyez le moment où ils entendent un bruit flippant, et ils ont peur et enfaite ils se rendent compte que c'est juste un chat ?
Oui, bien-sûr oui.
Et bah je ne suis pas juste un chat ok ? Je m'appelle Pierrick, j'aime la rando, j'aime le scrapbooking, et juste un chat, je trouve ça un peu réducteur.
Voilà.
On va voir ce qu'on peut faire oui.
Bon j'ai un autre modèle. Alors celui-ci, je l'ai préparé spécialement et je l'ai fais sur le modèle de mon épouse.
D'accord.
Voilà, alors, mon épouse.
Ah putain !
Elle ne vous plait pas ma femme ?
Non mais c'est pas mon style, c'est bien hein, mais c'est pas mon style.
Je l'ai vu. Je l'ai vu, ça y est c'est bon, vous pouvez l'enlever.
Non mais c'est pour v...
Arrête ça la !
Regarder ...
Bonjour !
Bonjour ...
Je tue des gens.
D'accord, jusqu'ici rien d'anormal.
Ouais.
Et vous faites ça avec une cagoule ?
Bah... C'est ça enfaite le problème c'est que... J'ai une cagoule parce que tout le monde a les masques cool et il ne me reste plus grand chose.
Est-ce que je peux vous montrez j'en ai quelques-uns.
Oui, bien-sûr.
Alors, j'ai ça.
Pas mal, ok, ouais.
Et ça...
Classique.
J'ai ça.
Il y a de l'idée, mais non.
Et j'ai ça...
Ah ! Celui là, il fait un peu peur.
Celui là ?
Ouais, moi j'opterais pour celui-là.
Ok.
Attendez ! Ah j'avais cru que c'était le vrai !
Ok, bon ça à l'air pas mal.
Allez-y.
Merci !
Vous m'avez fais peur !
Oui, je ne peux que apparaitre comme ça, c'est ça le problème.
Et ben je sais, justement.
Putain.
C'est vrai que ça doit pas être évident.
Non mais là, par exemple, je refaisais mes lacets juste.
Le bureau des plaintes Pokémon, c'est par là.
Ah non, non, non ! Je ne suis pas un Pokémon, je suis un monstre de série B. Je faisais très peur dans les années 70.
Ah, ça fait pas peur hein.
Heu, attendez. Même si je fais PIEUVRATON !
C'est quoi ça ? Pieuvraton ?
Pieuvraton, c'est mon nom de monstre.
Alors ? Dites-moi.
Alors, mon problème, c'est le nom que je porte.
C'est quoi ?
Alors mon prénom c'est Ça.
Heu... Quoi ça ?
Alors ça arrive tout le temps c'est chiant. Mon prénom c'est Ça !
Attendez, je ne comprend pas. Vous me dites ça mais vous ne me montrez rien avec vos doigts, je ne peux pas comprendre.
Je ne peux pas indiquer un truc parce que je parle de mon prénom.
Mon prénom c'est Ça ! Mon prénom égal Ça.
Pieuvraton ! Pieuvraton ! Pieuvraton !
Pieuvraton, Pieuvraton.
Pieuvraton, Pieu-vraton.
Pieuvraton-ton !
Mon prénom c'est Ça !
Vous vous foutez de ma gueule là, c'est Ça ?
C'est ça !
Super, belle mentalité.
Enfin non c'est pas ça !
Bon laissez tomber, de toute façon on y arrivera pas.
Oh je déconne !
Je vous fais marcher.
Bon, vous voulez quoi comme prénom ?
Lionel, j'aime bien.
Hey.
Ah encore vous.
Alors le masque c'est très bien, mais par contre je cale sur l'arme. J'en ai quelques-unes dans le sac, est-ce que je peux vous montrer ?
Allez-y, allez-y.
Alors... j'ai ça, ce truc la.
Ça, c'est un critérium...
Ça, quand t'arrive comme ça...
Mouais.
J'ai ça.
Hm, c'est super ça !
Hein ? Ça ?
Bah ouais, c'est lourd en plus ça, non ?
Ouais ...
Fais voir.
Oula, oui c'est bien lourd. C'est parfait ça.
Ok donc ça ! Et ça !
Parfait !
Ok, go !
Il est tellement attachant.
J'espère qu'il va tuer plein de gens.
Je crois qu'il arrive...